60 seconds on the clock 3 2 1 go Deontay
is off he has scored himself a $25 gift
card courtesy of
pomy he's on the hunt for two tickets to
an upcoming Bucks game if he makes it
makes it look easy this is for an
autographed
item
okay hold on hold
on I think we might have a new record
here for the poaty jackpot shot that was
incredible 43 seconds but listen if you
make this shot here you are going home
with
$10,000 Coury
ay listen if this is going to be anybody
this is the guy to do it Deonte this is
your jackpot shot for 10 grand in three
two one
go
[Music]
is taking a lap he's got to work that
one off congratulations to deante he is
going home with
$10,000 courtesy a the H about that for
the jackpot shot folks he's ready to go
he's got to get some press
[Applause]
share congratulations deante you are
going home
$10,000
richer